Here is a really pretty cable that can be
used to easily add interest
and texture to your next project.
It's 2 four stitch cables side by side,
surrounded by purl stitches.
This is a classic Arrows Out cable.
The multiple is 14 stitches by six rows.
And the chart looks like this.
This chart is written
for machine knitters.
It's shown from the purl side.
This symbol reflects knit stitches,
and this symbol reflects the manually
formed purl stitches that add
to the texture of this stitch pattern.
These symbols indicate the stitches
that will be crossed and the direction
of the transfers to form the cables.
To create this cable,
it's a two-step process.
Give it a try.
Cast on 40 stitches and knit a few
rows and add a little bit of weight.
Mark your needle bed as shown.
I like to just use a pencil.
It's easily erased.
You'll be crossing needles 2 through 5
on the left and needles
2 through 5 on the right.
Reading the cable symbols,
the broken lines are transferred first
and the solid lines are transferred last.
Think of it this way.
The first stitch is transferred will
appear on the public side of the knitting.
In this example, they'll be pointing
out away from the center of the design.
The second set of stitches transferred
will be behind those stitches.
Start by transferring
the first set of needles.
Put the stitches from needles four
and five on a two-prong tool,
turn the tool to get it
and the stitches out of the way.
Put the stitches from needle number two
and three on a two-prong tool and transfer
them left to fill the emptied needles.
Finish the cable by replacing the held
stitches to the newly emptied needles.
Repeat this on the right side of zero,
but we'll do it the opposite way.
Put the stitches on needles four and five
on the tool, turn the tool to make room,
transfer stitches number two and three
to the emptied needles,
and then transfer the held stitches
to the newly emptied needles.
It's time to knit the row
and complete the cable.
But first,
you may be tempted to pull out all
the needles to make
the knitting a little easier.
In this simple stitch pattern,
this may work, but it is suggested
that you avoid doing this.
If you're transferring more than just
a few needles like we are here,
it can distort the position
of the needles,
and pulling them all the way out could
distort it even more, making it even
more difficult to knit, not easier.
So keep those needles in middle position.
Following the pattern, knit six rows.
Now, step two of this process is to add
the column of purl
stitches next to the cables.
Working one column of the stitches
at a time, drop the stitch nearest
to the cable or needle number 6.
Position your latch tool at the bottom
of the column and drop the stitch down.
Latch up each stitch,
forming purl stitches on the side
that is away from you.
Then carefully rehang
that stitch on the needle.
Repeat this on needle number 7,
manually latching up a column of stitches.
Next, create columns of purl stitches
between the two cables on needles
left one and right one.
Finish by latching up stitches
number 6 and 7 on the right.
Following the pattern,
it's time to cross the cables again.
Now, if you're like me, you may not
want to wait to see your progress.
The first time I knit cables
on the machine, I crawed under
the table to see the results.
Now, you might consider holding your
camera behind your knitting
and taking a photo.
It's easier on the back and knees.
Happy knitting.